LAURENS FEENSTRA: I now see
there's many more of these tool
boxes here.
I was just walking
down the hall,
and I hadn't been given one of
these conference tool boxes.
So I was like, are
people bringing cats
to this conference?
Anyway, hi.
I'm Laurens.
I'm a product manager for
both Brillo and Weave.
I'm going to talk a bit
about Google services
for building devices at scale.
If you were here
the last sesh, you
would have heard Andrew
talk about Weave,
one of these services, and
our communication protocol
for devices-- and Sam, who
talked about Brillo DOS base
on Android.
So this session, I'm going
to go a bit more in-depth
about these Google services
and our philosophy behind it.
So these Google services
have three goals.
First of all, to help you build
a better device experience
for your end-user.
Weave is a good example, as it
is primarily end-user phasing.
I'll give an
example in a second.
Second, help you get
to market faster.
A lot of these services
provide core functionality
for your devices that everybody
will need, like Metrics,
like crash reporting.
So instead of you having to
build these things yourself,
we just include it
in the platform,
so that you have it
right out of the box.
And third, help you
operate at scale.
Over-the-air update service
is a good example of that.
It's very different if you're a
hobbyist and have only a couple
of devices versus having
millions of devices out there
and having to update
them in the field.
So for one, a device
experience for a user.
You may have, if you were
here in the previous session,
you may have seen this.
This is the set-up
flow for Weave.
A common problem that
we heard from developers
for devices right
now is, well, you
ship a device to your customer.
Your customer unbox the
device, plugs it in, but then
has to go to the app store
for his or her mobile phone
to find your app.
And let's imagine we're
building a camera, right?
So I go to the app store, and
I search for a camera app.
Some of your customers
will find the wrong app,
and you will drop them there.
So this is why we included
with Weave a device set-up
flow, where the moment the user
plugs in the device for Android
phones, the user says, OK,
Google, set up my device.
The device will show
up, and the flow
will guide them through
getting the Wi-Fi credentials,
assigning an owner, and
then right there installing
the right app that
you, as a developer,
told Weave to install.
So for the next of
the talk-- for rest
of the talk-- I'll still be
talking about services, and not
necessarily user facing, but
for you as a developer, starting
with how do I configure
these Google services?
So let's stick with
Weave for a second.
Or, let's talk first
about the process.
So you're developing
your device.
And at first, you want to find
the services that you want
and integrate them to devices.
Then you launch, these
devices become active,
and the services help
you iterate at scale.
First, monitor to
understand what's going on.
Second, improve.
If you find issues, to debug
them, find where they are,
and so you can fix them.
And thirdly, to
update your fleet.
Now the tool that
we're using for this
is the Brillo and Weave
Developer Console.
This helps you find those
services and integrate them.
This is a tool-- you
can find the tool
at weave.google.com/console,
if you're part of the developer
program.
So how does this work?
Configuring the Weave service.
If you go to the Configure
tab on the Developer Console,
you'll see the
Weave configuration.
And this will work
similarly for many services.
So the first thing that we'll
do is we'll ask you, hey,
what sort of device
are you developing?
In this case, as an example,
we're developing a camera.
So once you've told us, hey,
I'm developing a camera,
we'll give you the configuration
and give you an option
to download the templates
given that we know what type
of device you have.
Second, we help you find
additional documentation
and testing tools.
And thirdly, generate the
API keys and OAuth tokens,
for the service it
lists on the device
to communicate with our server.
Now, a little bit more
information about the tools
that we provide.
So, if you're using the Weave
service, one of the tools
is testing with
prototype devices.
Again, in the Weave
Developer Console,
in a tab called Your
Devices, the moment
you plug in a device that has
the Weave service enabled,
the device will show up.
And it allows you to
see its current state.
send commands to it.
So if you have a camera,
and you've just implemented,
let's say, turn on the
flashlight function,
you can send that command to
the device and debug and test
whether it actually works.
Then let me talk a bit about
other services besides Weave.
First, metrics
from field devices.
So if you're using
Weave out of the box,
there's a lot of out of the
box metrics that we give you.
So for devices, they
retain an active connection
to the Weave server, providing
it with state updates
and receiving commands
from client app.
And over this service data,
we collect aggregated steps.
So we can show you graphs
for online devices--
as you see here-- top
versions, top device
models, new registrations,
the number of commands
sent per hour.
So if you see those
tank, you know
there is something
wrong with your device.
And a command
distribution, which
gives you an idea of how
are my devices being used,
what sort of commands are being
sent, and in what proportion?
So, of course,
over these metrics,
consumer privacy
is very important.
So we never track a single
device, always an aggregation.
And for launch devices,
there is a 50 device minimum
that we track.
Then, the second
service, OTA updates.
So OTA updates is one of
the most important services
that we offer.
And you may have heard
other people talk about it.
And it's for two reasons.
One, we would love
for device makers
to continuously update your
devices, both for fixes
and for new functionality.
And the second is security.
If you want your devices
to have the latest security
features from Brillo and,
perhaps more importantly,
if you do discover that there
is an issue with your device,
you want to be able to send
an update to your devices
immediately.
So this is one of the
challenges I think we
face as an industry as a whole.
And if you read outside articles
from the press about IOT,
one of the things that
always comes up is security.
So Paul Cavell, that's another
product manager on Brillo,
will have a talk tomorrow
specifically about security.
Right now, I'm going to talk
a little more in-depth about,
what is the OTA update.
How does it work?
For now, it's
Brillo-specific, so you
have to build your
device on Brillo in order
to get our OTA update service.
So how does it work-- to push
an update to your devices
securely in five steps.
First, you use the
Brillo tools to create
a production build and sign it.
We have tools that allow
you to generate a key,
and then sign your
image using that key.
The second step that you do,
you go to the Brillo Weave
developer console and
you upload this binary.
What we do is then, once
we receive this binary,
is we look what are the
other versions out there.
And for the most common
versions out there, we generate,
delta so that your
devices don't have
to download the entire payload
every time, but instead
can download just the
things, just the deltas,
that is needed for this update.
We generate the payloads
that your devices
will be downloading and sign
it using a server-side key.
This is to verify
that for the device,
that this download,
this payload indeed
came from the Google
update servers and not
some malicious other servers.
So once you've
uploaded your binary
and the payloads are there,
you select a release channel.
So the release channel
for Brillo and Weave
works just like it
works on Chrome,
if you've ever
changed the release
channel for your browser.
Namely, at start,
we'll have three.
We'll have a stable
release channel.
This is where most of
your users will be on.
We have a beta release
channel, which is, you can see,
is a trusted tester channel.
And we have a developer
release channel,
which your team will use.
So each device knows
what channel it's on,
and in that case gets
a separate build.
So once you select
your release channel,
you schedule your push.
You select your version.
Select a percentage
of users that you'll
want to receive your build.
For instance, especially for
the stable release channel,
you probably don't want
to push out your release
to everybody at once.
So you select 1%
of my stable users,
I want to get this build first.
And you select your date.
Once you press Save,
step five is watching
your fleet update itself.
So as you can see
here, right now
we've pushed something
to the Dev channel,
the development build.
We've scheduled it for
November 24 at 12:00 AM.
So the process now is,
once this date is hit,
a device will check in, by
default, every five hours.
And it will send to the
Google Update server
its product ID, what product
am I, what version am I on,
and what channel am I on.
Then the server, if there
is a new download-- which,
in this case, there is--
will give it a download link.
The device starts
downloading the update,
verifies the payload,
that it indeed
came from the Google server.
And for Brillo devices, there's
two partitions, A partition
and B partition.
Let's say the device is now
running on the A partition,
and will start applying
the update on the B
partition in the background
while the device is still
active.
It applies the update.
And now it has to
decide when to reboot.
You may have seen that there's
1% left on older versions.
You may have
wondered why that is.
So for each product
category, there
may be a different
reboot process.
For instance, for
Chromebooks, the user
gets to decide when to reboot.
Even if the update
has been applied
on the other partition
in the background,
the user still wants to decide
themselves when to reboot.
So it could be that
some of the devices,
even though the update
is there, they simply
haven't rebooted to
the other version yet.
Another example is routers.
For routers, you
do not want to give
the user a notification when
there's a new update available.
But instead, you probably
want to have some heuristics--
between midnight
and 5:00 AM, if you
see very little traffic
on a network, that
is your moment to reboot.
This is important
because imagine
coming home from a night out,
having to go to the restroom,
you're at your door,
and at that moment
your smart door
lock decides that it
wants to apply and reboot.
That is not the optimal moment.
So for you as a developer,
we provide you tools
to decide the rebooting logic.
Crash reporting.
So imagine the situation
that we just saw.
You are pushing an update to
1% of your stable channel.
One of the metrics that
you want to be watching
is crashiness of your device.
What is the number of
crashes per hour that we're
seeing coming from your device?
That's someone you're
seeing here, the crashiness.
Old Brillo devices, by default,
come with a crash reporting
service, made with the open
source daemon called Breakpad.
These are open source
crash reporting tools.
So when you upload a new build
to our auto-update service,
with it, is uploaded
Symbol files, which
get sent to our crash server.
The moment one of
these devices crashes,
it will generate a mini-dump.
And when it comes
back online, it
will send the mini-dump
to our crash servers.
On our crash server, the
mini-dump and the Symbol files
are combined, and a
stack trace is generated,
and included in the report.
And that's what you're
seeing right here,
the number of reports that come
in with those stack traces,
which will help you
triage the problem.
Like if you suddenly see a
spike in the number of crashes,
we'll show you here,
what are the top 10
crashes that you received
in the last seven days.
Or you can minimize
that time window
to see, OK, what
are the top crashes
from this particular version
that I just uploaded?
And we'll show
you, in this case,
if you look at the
top two, the top crash
has 30% of the total crashes.
The second cluster--
a cluster of four--
is 15% of each of the crashes.
So if you solve
those two issues,
you've already solved 45%
of your total crashes.
And the final column
is, what is the delta
with the previous time period.
So with this, you can decide,
OK, these are my top issues.
And then dive into an
individual report within one
of these clusters showing
you the stack trace,
and some meta data of what
was going on on that device
at the moment of crash.
The final service I
want to talk about that
is included with Brillo and
Weave are performance graphs.
These come from a
metric reporting
service that periodically
gathers data from the device.
For instance, in this case, it
is what is the data partition
usage in megabytes?
Other examples are CPU usage,
memory usage, or page faults.
Because this is data
generated from a device,
like crash reports,
privacy is important.
No PAI is collected
in these histograms.
And an opt-in is required
from the end-user
during device setup before this
metric service becomes active.
This is useful, and we can track
over time and over versions,
like what is my data
partition usage?
And does my CPU usage
go up over time?
And if a lot of
users complain, hey,
my device is
starting to act slow,
you can use this to figure out,
hey, what causes these field
devices to act slow.
Over the course of this year, we
will start adding more services
to Brillo and Weave devices.
We'd like to get
your input as well.
What sort of itches do you
have that you'd like scratched?
And what sort of
functionality would you
like to see in the
Brillo and Weave platform
that we could help
provide for you?
So tomorrow, there
will be office hours
from 12:00 PM to 2:00 PM.
So come ask your
questions there.
There's CodeLabs going on,
on enabling Google services
and pushing OTA updates, if you
want to get your hands dirty
and play around with this.
I'm Laurens Feenstra,
I'm a product manager,
and I hope to see you there.
Thank you.
Any questions for Google
services, for devices to scale?
There's two
microphones to decide,
and there's one
microphone up there,
if anybody has a question
they'd like to ask.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
For OTA updates, do
you have to allocate
a double the size of memory
for the original code
and in the updated code?
And then you can swap
one for the other
when you've finished the update?
LAURENS FEENSTRA: Can we
put the volume up a little?
I've had trouble
hearing the question.
AUDIENCE: I was asking--
oh, that's louder.
Do you need twice as much
code space for OTA updates
in order to hold both the
original code and the updated
code?
LAURENS FEENSTRA: No, it
will update on the fly.
So you do need
twice as much space,
because you have two
partitions, right?
Brillo has two
partitions by default.
But it will update on the fly.
This update's smart about that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
LAURENS FEENSTRA: Hi.
Yes, up there.
AUDIENCE: If the
customer decides
not to register with
Google, their Brillo device,
can the customer
still receive updates?
LAURENS FEENSTRA:
That's a great question.
Yes, it can.
The update service is
separate from Weave.
As in, it would require an
active internet connection,
of course, but the
update server still
pings in even if the customer
decides not to register
the device with Weave.
Basically, the fact that it
is Google in the background
is opaque to the end-user and
the end-user shouldn't care.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAURENS FEENSTRA: All right?
Oh, there's one question there.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I would like to know how does
it compare with platforms
like openHAB that tries to
integrate all the smart home
automation systems, like,
for example, SmartThings Hub,
and like Philips Hue or Insteon.
So, do you have something
like that for integrating
all these smart home systems?
LAURENS FEENSTRA: That will be
a great question for Andrew,
who is the PM for Weave.
So if you come to
our office tomorrow,
you could ask him that question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
the reason I asked
was, you were talking
about number of crashes.
I was thinking like, if
you could have something
like that in your system that
supports them, you could say,
OK, this SmartThings
is better than,
for example, Insteon smart--
LAURENS FEENSTRA: Right.
So you can use a
peer comparison.
Like how crashy is this?
Yeah, so for our crash
servers, of course
you can only see
the crash reports
for your specific device.
By default, we don't give
you access to other devices.
It is interesting
idea, though, to do
a bit of a peer comparison.
Of all the cameras, which
camera is the most crashy?
But, yeah.
For now, no.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
LAURENS FEENSTRA: All right.
Thanks for listening, everybody.